and the multiple storms in texas and
throughout the country are adding a new
urgency to the bipartisan push for new
funding for america states and cities
in a letter more than 400 mayors are
imploring congress to approve 350
billion dollars in aid
as part of the president's coveted
relief plan ed o'keefe spoke with the
mayor
from each party one's a democrat
city government is hurting revenues are
gone
the other a republican we are certainly
doing a little bit more with a little
bit less
and these two mayors of baltimore and
oklahoma city agree congress needs to
come together quickly to help cities
struggling to balance the books
what's happening in big cities isn't
unique smaller towns like waterville new
york and waterloo iowa are also
struggling to provide essential services
as tax revenues dry up
so they're all asking for help i'm still
looking for the mayor of a city
blue or red who hasn't
you know experienced a negative
financial impact from the pandemic
oklahoma city's republican mayor david
holt
says the downturn caused by the pandemic
means he can't make good on a law passed
two years ago
that requires hiring 120 new police
officers
that has meant you know freezing the
hiring of lots of positions
especially in police and fire because
that's that's basically two thirds of
our budget
in baltimore democratic mayor brandon
scott
says a drop in tourism revenue means
he's facing at least a 30 million dollar
shortfall
convention center is a coveted testing
center and a vaccination site so no
one's having conventions there
last year congress gave hundreds of
billions of dollars to cities and states
but only to pay for covet-related
expenses like buying protective
equipment
baltimore and oklahoma city each got
more than 100 million dollars
now president biden's nearly two
trillion dollar american rescue plan
would provide about 350 billion dollars
in direct aid to cities and states
polls show a majority of americans
support the president's legislation
but most republican lawmakers say it's
too expensive
and that taxpayers in one part of the
country shouldn't have to bail out
somebody else's
cash-strapped city this legislation this
proposal is a blue state
bailout we should help on covert relief
i want targeted
help for people but to bail out these
blue states makes no sense
but republican holt from ruby red
oklahoma
disagrees the idea that that you know
there are
places that haven't experienced an
economic downturn and therefore
an impact on their city services that
place doesn't exist
and democratic mayor scott is less
diplomatic
this is about a once in a lifetime
pandemic and the fallout
that was made worse ironically by the
inaction
of a republican president to still be
talking in partisan talking points
just shows that we still have folks who
do not want to grow up
do their job to help american citizens
the white house is still trying to build
republican support for the legislation
which the house is set to pass
as early as next week democrats on the
hill are hoping to get that bill
to the president by mid-march gail it
also includes proposed 1400
direct payments to struggling americans